قلتها مع حريق كبير مخيما للاجئين
الرهنغيا في مدينه كوكس بازار جنوب شرقي
بنغلاديش واظهرت مقاطع فيديو الحريق
الكبيره الذي اندلع بالمخيم والتصاعد
السنه النار والدخان من الموقع وسط توتر
كبير بين اللاجئين دون ورود انباء عن
الخسائر البشريه حتى الان وقدرت منظمه
عدد المتضررين من الحريق اليوم ب 12 الف
لاجئ بعد احتراق اكثر من 2000 من خيامي
ومساكن اللاجئين الخشبيه ادوا يعيش اكثر
من مليون من مسلم الروهنديا في ملاجئ تم
بناؤها بطريقه بدائيه في مخيمات كوكس
بازارد التي فروا اليها هربا من اعمال قمع
قالوا ان سلطه ميانمار مارستها بحقهم
معنى الان من دكا عاصمه بنغلاديش مراسل
الجزيره تنفير شودري بدايه التضحت
المعلومات او الانباء
المعنيه بالاسباب الكامنه وراء هذا الحريق
الذي اتهم المخيم
لدينا من مخيم كوكس ومن رجال الاطفاء بان
الفي كوخ او خيمه
احترقت بالكامل سيكون هناك المزيد ولكن
الى الان ليس هناك انباعا وفيات او اصابات
وتحقيقات ما زالت جاريه فما
علينا ان نفهمه ان هذه النيران اخمدت
قبل دقائق ولذلك المعلومات ما زالت شحيحه
ولكن كان هناك في السابق حوادث هذه حيث
شردت 50,000 شخص
معظم
معظمها تتات
ى استخدام اسطوانات للطبخ
وهي تستخدم الغاز واحيانا يحدث حادث كهذا
في الاسطوانه والحال كهذا في العاده ولكن
في بعض الحالات
ربما يكون هناك اعمال تخريب او عمل متعمد
لان هناك عصابات تعيش في وسط هذا المخيم
وهناك ايضا عصابات تتنافس فيما بينها
ولذلك هم يطلقون النار على بعضهم البعض او
يقومون بحرق مناطق بعضهم البعض اذا قد
يكون هذا العمل ناجم عن عمل متعمد ولكن
لسنا متاكدين الى الان هذا المخيم مزدحم
ويحوي
الف شخص وهو اكبر مخيم للاجئين في العالم
تقصد بان عدد المتضررين كبير كيف هي
اوضاعهم الان وكنت قد ذكرت بان الحريق تم
اخماده قبل قليل كيف هي اوضعهم الان والى
اين سيذهبون بعد احتراق قيامهم او مساكنهم
البسيطه هذه
العديد من المستشفيات الميدانيه التي تقوم
بتقديم خدماته الطوارئ
وخدمات الاعتناء بحوادث الحريق بالاضافه
الى ان هناك مستشفى حكومي قريب وفي كاكس
بازار وهو يتعامل مع ضحايا الحريق بعض
الحالات هي
صعبه جدا ويتم نقل اصحابها الى دكه وهذه
هي طريقه اداره شكرا هذه الحوادث بشكل عام
في
من العاصمه البنكلاديشيه دكا مراسله
الجزيره تنفير تشادري شكرا جزيلا لك